can you believe that people pee on each
other for sexual pleasure and poop on
each other and beat each other's ass and
all the crappy all the ridiculous [__]
people do for their sex Pleasures good
God yeah whatever happened to just just
[__] just having sex for a few
minutes and just having like a TV dinner
or whatever I know the good things in
life right yeah dude oh God sometimes I
just
when I was young you know we grew up
with like a more tradition in America
you know with like the Pledge of
Allegiance simple stuff you know hand
jobs I don't even think they do hand
jobs anymore I think they do
they might you know they might but but
it was like that you know there was kind
of like
now they call it tug jobs oh they do
yeah
I've seen that on the internet oh damn
aggressive well a lot of these women are
also they're coming in hot you know
they're coming in a little you know yeah
the women are acting like the men did
when I was in high school well that's a
thing so yeah they're tugging now it
used to be a little more you know hand
feels a little bit more
comfortable I think yeah tug feels like
hey let's [__] get up you know yeah
let's get it done and get out of here
yeah that's kind of how women are now
and the men are kind of like the they
seem like the girls were in high school
like well I don't know what that means
yeah what the hell [__] turned around
I'm so glad I'm past the sex urge I'll
tell you what I said you know I know I
look better now than I ever did if I
look this good when I was 20 I don't
know I would have made something of
myself
[Laughter]
you know
oh God I don't have I would honestly I
would I think I would even take you out
on a date I think you would yeah I think
you're really pretty oh you're so nice I
believe that too that is so nice you
know how happy that makes an old woman
if I was 40 years older I'd snap you and
half like a potato chip yeah
do you oh yeah are there any things that
you miss about sex as you get older do
you think well I had an unfortunate
experience that ended all my sex urges
and all my sex thoughts
uh because you know when you're old
things happen to you as a woman if
you're not going to take all the
hormones you know and you're just going
to try to age gracefully with your
vagina and all well the one thing that
was
the one thing that was shocking is that
I found out the only thing thin on me is
my vaginal walls oh yeah
and that's what happens the older you
get they get more and more thin so you
know and you know your husband he's
getting old too so of course he's got to
go on the Viagra because you know this
and that and the other well what ends up
happening just isn't good and so there I
was every time I you know we did it well
I got a horrible I what are they called
UTI UTI I think it's uterine or
something
yeah
and uh the last time I got it was the
last time I had sex well they had to
take me to the hospital I started peeing
blood in route at Ralph's at Ralph's oh
wow I've done something I've never done
that at Ralph's yeah it was so scary
they had to take me to the hospital and
uh they had to give me three morphine
shots for my uh whatever it was to let
loosen the bladder thing oh and they
give it to you right in your vagina oh
no no they give it to me right in the
butt oh no not in the vagina thank God
because I I would have jumped out the
window and just scared myself oh if I
see anybody put it down yeah I would God
I would hate that but then I was like
Sorry Charlie to my boyfriend Sorry
Charlie you're gonna have to whatever
you know whatever you do don't just
whatever keep it to yourself yeah I'm
done I'm over it I'm never going through
that again God that people say well
there's other ways to make love you know
you can get with your partner and blah
blah so you know we do we like to watch
the ID channel on the mass murders we
lay there in bed together and
watch the mass murders and that's just
as uh
what do you call it satisfying to me
which we try to solve the cases and this
and that the True Crime that's exciting
but you know I look back at people I go
you're so proud of yourself for the
having sex thing
they're so damn proud of theirselves
like every goat on Earth don't do it
it's so yeah I mean look first of all a
good Dateline episode will make me come
to be honest
yeah the good ones the early ones I
thought were better some of the girls I
mean they've kind of repackaged some of
them
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one